Tariq Aziz had the best idea I've heard
he said why don't we call Isis the
non-believers why are we calling them
Isis just call them non-believers when
you do that you take away take away the
Mormon I love you I'm sorry the Muslim
sure I love I love that kind of stuff
there are ways to PB people without
hands well thank you for holding my hand
you have a very heavy hand a strong hand
ah you got a strong ah I can't all right
let me get a good grip really squeezing
no cuz you had me in the wrong position
now now what's up bro no don't try to
get a good who I can grip see that do it
no [ __ ] bro bro don't [ __ ] it up Oh miss
control dude I was a wrestler one thing
about me I ride risks heavy I'm a heavy
wrist rider I'm a dick diver but a heavy
wrist rider as well dick diver is while
I'm deep in your rump er you know that
right when you feel my balls and I'm
working your [ __ ] wrist you feel my
boss my American balls slapping up
against your [ __ ] white privileged
ass that's what I did every time I push
him the silymarin and then when I come
it's like this
[Music]
and then you go oh oh I had to go ain't
gonna be a time getting me this is a lie
girl do you know my name
I think so I never really usually date
Asian you know a name but you're super
tall and also I've heard you singing on
your tinder profile and I love talking I
see insane so that's sort of what I'm
doing here I change out starving you're
starving fire kid thanks for coming oh
my god what would you like to order my
servants right here oh you're sorry man
no my servants are here oh he's big hi
see anything you up the phone with giant
servant you [ __ ] up tell me take your
girl down hey bro you just [ __ ] serve
me my food and shut the [ __ ] there you
go hi um why are you holding that tray
kids I have well no I
it's a romantic thing he said [ __ ] it's
a five-course meal okay he's talking to
me in a really aggressive way and I
don't feel comfortable can you calm down
yes I don't like his ears they're making
my stomach turn
they look like tortellini and I was
gonna order the tortellini and I don't
want it you find yourself on any special
diet now because your body's taken so
much punishment he just do it I mean
like now I try to eat I mean last night
I trained I got down to about 11 and I
think I those little twigs things I
think I had like 14 he worried word
craft services and he has a daunting
goes I mean this I'm like all right
whatever I don't care I'll eat it and
I'll work it off and he's like he's
justified how to do the same thing I
just met you I why are you how about
last time the common source in here was
groans I'm gonna have half I'm gonna
have this half he's making it tomorrow
more and I run all right they're all
getting laid in the world football
league from Sacramento we won the World
Championship you know the NFL had it it
was their kind of farm league thing
right and I played with a dude named Jon
Niese who was on the first year of MTV
the house thing real in the real world
he was the model on it right and he was
our punter and he was so vain that he
would have a dip cup when he'd habit
he'd have like a chocolate bark and he
take a bite of the chocolate need chew
it like four or five times swish them
around spit it out wow I'm like you know
what I'm never blow up on a hand you
know hot dogs at Coney Island er yeah
and hamburgers and so my deal is this I
ain't no frickin model right I'm a D
lineman I'm a frickin crow Magnum dude
but I don't like being fat and I have
you know now I have an image and and you
know and I don't feel good if I share
him fat and you know essentially I meant
and I want to be at the best of my game
so I'm not vain by any stretch of
imagination but it's another competitive
thing it's like if they don't want to be
in as best as I can but yet I'm not
giving up food you know so I'm gonna
have to work my ass even harder because
I ain't giving up that so do you just
eat base eat whatever you want buddy
just work it off when I'm in the back
there everyone dude you and Diaz what
happened you and didn't like a god he
cares though Tony super close with Diaz
and he human
Tony facetimed there no right before I
was like dude I'm chill on my deck and I
get a face time it's Nate Diaz I already
knew what it was gonna be about and I
was like deal I have like you know I I
loved I liked name and I don't you know
me I don't just like anyone yeah I just
want this storm to pass
mmm I want the storm to pass but yeah
wait before just one more thing so
there's been subtitles Brian's already
like talked about on his Instagram
that's all subtitles yeah yeah so it's
obvious the subtitles are writing
something fake they see that you said he
teed off on him when you said I think
you're off on this I said I think you're
off on this down I don't know any girls
I think you're awful I think you're off
on this one yeah so just for people that
saw those videos yes such lame song yeah
yeah people and I told Brian he didn't
you need me to acknowledge it but you
know Brian he's my brother
so yes yeah Rogan was like yeah you can
tell it's [ __ ] and he was I've come
out and do a video saying that I'm like
I'm just I just want to go away like
that's fake I'm not gonna give them
attention or anything it's just
past it's all good I like Nate some of
the animations like that da sprat right
yeah how great was that with me Gucci
shoes and all that and then they made
the animation like I'll kill this with
humor man like it's what are we talking
about
I like Nate there's I've zero hard
feelings against him I don't think he
hates me
it's a noun that and it's also that
situation you know Nate's watching
Connor fight I've been kind of this huge
voice for Connor and this whole thing so
you know he point his gun towards me I
get it man emotions are high back there
it's over it's done but yeah that videos
fake news yeah I I would first of all I
would never disrespect a fighter and say
T DAW like do she move I even a guy that
I would beat I've never seen man i teed
off on yours alone another guy who's
super talented who beat another really
town fight I never said he Tina those
teed off and explaining a fight like
that it isn't in my vocabulary it's just
not me and I don't know what that fake
news site is that report something like
that but maybe they maybe that's what
they thought I don't know but you got to
do your you know to be taken serious I
don't know you can you can hear it's the
audios Bab you can hear that you're not
saying that so they did that on purpose
I wouldn't make but he creates news you
know like that's what they're looking
for